hi there steve coffman here
today again talking about language
learning as usual that's what i like to
do twice a week here on this channel
and i want to share with you some of my
own experience you know i'm not saying
that i'm an expert on anything i can
only share with you
my experience of language learning and i
want to talk today about how we can make
sure that we stay the course
because the secret to success in
language learning is to stay with it
not to be discouraged so i kind of
looked at some of the things that i'm
doing what is it that maintains my
enthusiasm that kind of keeps me going
the first thing i think is very
important is
you know don't worry about what you
forget you're going to forget
be feel convinced that
as you expose yourself to more of the
language you are gradually improving and
i sense this now i'm listening to
content
in persian
which is difficult
but i'm beginning to get a bit of a feel
for it even if i don't have all the
words
i know that just this pounding is like
i'm slowly getting better i know i'm
getting better i'm not worried about how
much better i'm getting i'm not worried
about what i forget i just know that
absorbing the language is improving
you know my ability and at least to
comprehend persian now some of the
things that i have done
i have asked my
sahara who is my iranian my most
important you know helper teacher
resource
she has not only created a number of
very good stories about herself about
what she does likes to do her travels
she has created these circling questions
for her own content which we discussed
the last time
but she's also gone into some of our
more difficult content
such as the parghar
you know podcast from the bbc and she
has created these circling questions so
you know and this leads me to the second
point in order to stay motivated number
one
rest assured if you compete can continue
to expose yourself to the language you
will get better
point number two vary it don't go at the
same type of content over and over again
don't try to learn the conjugation
tables don't try to stay with just
beginner content don't even try to stay
with difficult content make sure you
vary the content so
with
sahra
creating these circling questions for
the difficult content
obviously she can't cover you know
she has divided these difficult content
items for me into
seven eight minutes segments and within
each segment she has created these
circling questions
and that doesn't cover all of the
vocabulary but it it gives me a bit of a
toehold on some of it it increases my
confidence
um and it helps me then eventually to
you know
go back in there and listen to it again
so
uh i vary it similarly i went running
the other day
and i was listening to the mini stories
in persian so by varying it and of
course the win many stories for me are
a confirmation of everything that i have
achieved because when i started in
persian the many stories were just noise
i didn't know how i was ever going to
get to where i could understand them and
now they're very very easy because i
vary it so i have
easier content
middle level content with circling
questions more difficult content with
circling questions i go back to the many
stories so that this kinda keeps me
going so again in order to make sure
that you stay the course and you don't
get frustrated number one
please accept the fact that if you
continue to expose yourself to the
language you will get better gradually
not always noticeably but you get better
you become more familiar the brain
becomes more familiar with certain
expressions certain words certain uh
you know connector words that always
show up uh certain forms of verbs
slowly you become familiar even if you
can't produce them all the time
number two
very things varied between difficult
content which can be you know
frustrating easy content which can
become boring
intermediate content
uh i should point out by the way
that we've had a good response to this
my request for you know people to help
us to create these
as we have for the iranians we have the
iranians where people are iranians talk
about themselves and we're looking for
the same in french or in chinese or
other languages
no someone said could you do this in
english to give us an idea of
what it's supposed to look like
well i will be putting up within the
next couple of days
i have recorded and i've had transcribed
and i'm going to create some circling
questions
for some english examples of what it is
we're looking for
so you'll see that
but so this is all part of the sort of
varying the range of difficulty of what
you're doing so you're not always trying
to you know
attack the same kind of material now the
third element
in making sure you stay with it is you
have to recognize that
if you want to speak well you have to
speak a lot so there is no way that if
you speak occasionally
even once or twice a week with a tutor
or even more often with a tutor
you know on skype
you're not going to become really good
at using the language
so you build up this capability
and and that should satisfy if you're
building up your comprehension your
vocabulary you're building up the
potential
and if you are then put in a situation
where you have to use
or can use the language a lot you will
improve very quickly so when you get
that opportunity take advantage
speak don't sit back and just listen
speak with mistakes it doesn't matter
but you have to
put yourself in that position eventually
in order to speak well so you can do all
these other things to build up your
capability your potential but eventually
you have to speak a lot in order to
speak well and when you speak a lot
you'll make mistakes and it doesn't
matter and then you go back into
your
listening and reading and some difficult
content and then easier content to kind
of
build up some some basic structures that
you can use in your conversation because
anytime you know in conversation we're
going to use a small
subset of the total number of words that
we understand our active vocabulary is
going to be smaller much smaller than
our passive vocabulary but that's a good
thing because then you understand and
gradually that active vocabulary
increases so in order to you know not
don't expect too much of yourselves
recognize that all of this exposure is
gradually making better making you
better
second of all
vary the kind of content you're
listening to vary it by
level of difficulty or even by nature
you know if you like reading about
grammar read about grammar but don't
just do that or don't just do your anki
deck if that's what you like to do make
sure you vary it
and then look for opportunities to speak
but if you don't have a lot of
opportunity to speak
don't
you know expect of yourself that you're
going to be able to speak well you won't
but build up that capability so that
when you have that opportunity you can
take full advantage and make sure you do
take full advantage and don't worry
about
you know problems mistakes whatever
inadequacies so i hope that's helpful
because i think the biggest problem is
when people give up too early
and
if they stay the course they will
eventually
achieve their language goals
so there you have it how to stay the
course and not let the frustrations of
language learning
make you lose interest